hey guys my name is Jess today it is the
second of june and this is your Thursday
edition up games but news here is the
big sponge Konami have released a pretty
sweet-looking trailer for their next to
Metal Gear project good news it's a
Metal Gear Solid 3 snaky to remake bad
news its face to tinker machine although
we won't be able to get our hands on
this Japanese pinball gambling machine
in the West we can all appreciate the
trailer which is recreated the boss and
naked snakes final confrontation with
gorgeous high def models and
environments using metal gear solid 5
Fox engine we also get a glimpse of
updated models of the pain the fury the
fear and the end the pachinko machine
will roll out across arcades in Japan
this autumn probably no actual mgs3
remake here but it's a cool watching on
the list Ubisoft have confirmed that
watch dogs too is going to be D through
this year the publisher sent around an
email detailing their plans for e3 where
they said they will present highly
anticipated titles such as watchdogs 24
honor and Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon
wildlands they added that they also plan
to unveil some surprises you bz 3
conference is scheduled for monday jun
13 at 1pm it was previously suggested
that watch dogs too would launch before
the end of April 2017 and will
supposedly have a new tone at whatever
that means an image of what could well
be the protagonist of watchdogs to
appeared online a short while ago or
being the loop finally in fairly serious
news French media conglomerate vivendi
looks to be angling to take over uses
Michelle Guillermo chief executive of
mobile developer gameloft and brother of
you stop sphere ECMO is expected to
resign after game last shareholders back
to a hostile takeover bid from
fendi the camera brothers have been
doing their best to fight back against
vivendi who seem to be buying up stakes
in the publicly traded companies in
order to gain more control and
potentially conduct an unsourced to take
over the vendor used to own a
controlling stake in Activision Blizzard
they eventually managed to buy
themselves back in October 2015 soon
after vivendi bought a minority stake in
both gameloft and ubisoft which has
become increasingly less minor over time
vivendi has said they have no plans to
take over Ubisoft but insisted that
their eighteen percent stake in the
publisher means they should have
representation at the board level the
Guillermo brothers only control fifteen
percent of the board of directors
currently is previously said they will
quote fight to preserve our independence
and called vivendi's investment unwanted
let me know down in that comment section
what you think of the vivendi take over
and be sure to head to gamespot well
we've got stories on flight and over
watches cheetahs being bad that is
everything I have you today we do join
me again tomorrow for our last show in
Sydney for a while I will see them